there are songs about the brutality
inflicted on what were called comfort
women Lee yong-soo watches on as she
listens to her own story and that's of
the tens of thousands of women forced to
work in Japanese military brothels
during the Second World War
this latest bronze statue has arrived
from the US and it represents comfort
women from Korea China and the
Philippines the circle here is completed
when the gap is filled
despite the artistic displays the
comfort women say they have yet to
receive closure to their ordeal still
waiting for an official apology from
japan's Prime Minister comfort women is
a creation of the Japanese they claim we
went on our own volunteer Lee to make
money servicing the Japanese soldiers
what an incredible lie I'm 92 it's a
perfect age to fight and receive an
apology from the Prime Minister a
sentiment felt by 88 year-old Kim
jang-soo and 13 years of age she was
forced into labor by the Japanese at the
factory they gave us half a piece of
bread to eat we were so hungry we ate
all the grass in odometry we lost our
hair we slept with our shoes on for fear
of air raids above our heads we were
slaves are they denies it on furious Ali
must give us the truth and reparation
[Music]
Japan says it's settled the dispute
under a 1965 treaty by offering South
Korea 500 million dollars but South
Korea disbanded the fun last year saying
it was flawed decades of distrust
between the neighbors has spilled onto
the streets these protestors want Japan
to apologize to the comfort women
they're also demanding Japan lifts its
restrictions on exports of high-tech
materials vital for the South Korean
industry Japan site security concerns
South Koreans think it's retaliation for
the wartime labor dispute it's not Japan
we're against but the Arby government
hasn't apologized to the forced workers
and the sex slave victims instead it
digs deeper into their wounds with their
economic retaliatory moves we refuse to
use Japanese products a South Korea
celebrated 74 years of independence from
Japanese colonial rule president moon
jae-in called for talks to end the trade
dispute a chance for the u.s. allies to
make amends with its past and present
certified at and Jazeera